herr leute herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich nehme das jetzt gerade
um ein uhr nachts auf morgen aber hier
von 10 bis 19 uhr unis heißt es fakt ich
habe heute wieder über eine sache
nachgedacht die mich sonst auch sehr
viel beschäftigt und zwar darüber wie
sehr man sich auch so als youtube
verändert ja sie müsste ich mir vor
augen halten dass video was wir uns
jetzt gleich anschauen werden es ist
zweieinhalb jahre
das video ist zweieinhalb jahre alt und
die person die da drin ist ist wirklich
ein anderer mensch ist übrigens sollte
jetzt irgendwie gleich irgendwo besoffen
das ding rein platz in die ganze
aufnahme das liegt daran dass einmal mit
bewohnern gerade geburtstag feiert und
der im ganzen haufen länger als
alkoholiker
es kann leicht nämlich ganz theoretisch
rausschneiden aber ja ich habe mich im
hintergrund geladen können wir kurz nein
ich will keine untertitel
seit wann ich habe doch die qualität ein
da bin ich zum ersten mal beim
verdreckten drexler gut an ist also lass
ich bin schon so ein bisschen wie
möglich war gar noch beim training heißt
soll ich in die video irgendwas sagen
verwendet sich gegen mich dass eine
andere person die gerade spricht okay
leute erster frame wir lassen das jetzt
mal auf uns wirklich lasse ich jetzt mal
so ziehen sie von den zeiten schauen
dieses bild an
hier habe ich diese kacke gerendert
alter habe ich die auf meine fucking
muffin packung geändert was soll der
scheiß hört man die ränder ansicht dass
oben unten links und rechts schwarzer
einander schwarze ränder hätte man nicht
rein packen können damals auf angelegt
hätte partie und so erwarte ich nichts
zu essen
dieser typ hat gerade richtig glück
gehabt ich habe dem es mal okay das war
nicht so schlau ich hab im sap bot mit
meinem bogen gegeben oder bin ich hinter
ihm hat hingehauen
es war ich bitte leute ich schwöre euch
ich erinnere mich gerade dann wieder ich
habe mich echt in diesem video wirklich
geschehen
das war so richtig so an du hast deine
eigenen bruder verraten weil ich mag
seine rolle minecraft getötet haben
minecraft real life und so manches echte
leben achtung und jetzt leute gebt euch
gebt euch mister germany wasser in
germany mister world 2014
fünf sekunden auf sieger in der gamestar
erstmal broadcasting button erwischt
jetzt ist man noch die hardcore-gamer
zeiten ich habe damals nicht mit einer
emmy maus gezockt sowie jetzt früher
habe ich einfach mit einer laptop maus
gezockt so groß ist eine richtige maus
ok und einen laptop maus ist ungefähr so
groß wie die mit dem letten irgendwohin
schleppt und ich konnte diese laptop
maus einfach immer nur so mit zwei
fingern halten und so habe ich gezückten
aufgenommen ich glaube ein dreiviertel
jahr lang oder so bis ich dann mal
dahinter kam dass wir doch eventuell
meine maus kaufen könnte okay das ist es
ja was dabei aufgestockt oder soweit
3218 speed shift und winkel getroffen
können ein bisschen länger drinbleiben
im backofen oder auf jeden fall backofen
ich hab mir zugehört ja weiß ich mehr in
der rnz kräften oder erst hast ja schon
etwas abwesend sind tutor sofort das ist
wieder so typisch das ist auch so eine
eigenschaft die ich bis heute nicht
verloren ab einfach immer und überall so
im kopf woanders zu sein auf total
verzählt verteilt man braucht dringend
was zu fressen
wahnsinns kennt ihr das kennt ihr das
die sprüche damals war anschauen
das war schon top tier kennt ihr das
aber leute eine frage leute leute kennt
ihr das von ihr bruder an hunger stirbt
schreibt seien die kommentare
dafür nämlich afrika edition das geil
das geil ist geil die sonst itate habe
ich damals schon gut gedroppt alter was
ist das palace oder irgendwas von
brocade publikum präsenz
ich brauche dringend was die frames
nicht regenerieren am arsch der welt
ich kann ich ja noch nicht trocken ich
war schon die ganze zeit wie ich
versuche es einfach alles schnell kaputt
zu machen jetzt auf die mission wir
müssen jetzt kraft retten
das gehört leute wir begeben uns auf die
mission wir retten tragen crafter wenn
man sie jetzt den titel des videos
angeschaut hat könnte man eventuell
denken dass diese rettungsmission
vielleicht nicht so erfolgreich war
scheiße scheiße
ok jetzt kriegst du aber auch die fresse
du kannst nicht [ __ ] no escape bogens
keller wieder am start
kontron com standort nicht getötet
falter denn für uns und ich hatte nichts
ich hätte ihnen so geklappt stehen
wechselt aber ohne zu essen gehabt
dieser typ hat gerade richtig glück
gehabt
ich hab ihm erstmal okay das war nicht
so schlau ich hab mit meinem bogen
gegeben oder ab in dem bin ich hinter
ihm hat ihn grauen das war ich bitte
bitte nein nein moment leute nein moment
moment moment das ist alles eine
riesengroße verschwörung des video heißt
es tut mir so leid max war ich dachte
ich ja max getötet aber passt auf passt
auf achtet darauf was max sagt achtet
darauf so scheiße scheiße
ok jetzt kriegst du auf die fresse du
kannst nicht [ __ ] us case shiller
wieder am start
kontron com standort nicht getötet
so solle jetzt mal entscheiden dieses
cento 47 wurde von der insel game
marketing genau moment max ok scheiße
ich wurde gerade getötet
740 ist max aber achtet darauf dass in
dem moment der typ den ich verfolge noch
am leben ist
das heißt
ich habe max tatsächlich in diesem video
nicht getötet ich war unschuldig die
ganze zeit bis zum anfang des videos
habe ich mir falsche vorwürfe gemacht
ich war es einfach nicht das fühlt sich
einfach gut an ich dachte die chance
altes video an und es ist wie immer so
dass das verbot aber ich fühle mich
tatsächlich besser nach dem video ich
habe max damals nicht getötet und alle
neuen display können sie ihren like in
können vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken
das video nicht zu denken
was wenn ihr nur für kommentare erfreuen
sie sogar ein guter grund darf sich
immer wieder gerne
seht ihr dass ihr seht ihr das hier